[موسيقى]
هذه البقعه من العالم تنفرد بسر من
الاسرار الطبيعيه التي لا يعرف بامرها
كثير من سكان كوكب الارض
انها ولايه شمال كردفان الواقعه في غرب
السودان التي تقع بدورها في الشرق
الافريقي
وتعتبر هذه الولايه وجاراتها دره التاج في
صناعه فريده من اهم واندر المجالات
الصناعيه على المستوى العالمي وهي صناعه
الصمغ كما انها جزء من حزام طبيعي يعرف
بحزام الصمغ العربي
لمعرفه قصه الصمغ هذه قررنا الانطلاق في
مهمه استكشافيه خاصه
متجهين صوب ولايه شمال كردفان التي تعد
معقل الصمغ العربي
الشجره الصمغه العربيه شجره محوريه
تتمحور حولها كل حياه المواطنين
ليس الصمغ العربي هو المنتج الوحيد من
الشجره ولكن الشجره هي في الكلور هي حياه
للناس
ولكن المنتج السحري
واحنا بنسميه منتج سحري
من فوائد معروفه للجميع
مواطينا هنا في شمال كردفان احنا لا نعرف
تاريخ لهذه الشجره شجره مما الناس يعني
وجدت وجدت هذه الشجره يعني
تجمع التقارير والدراسات العلميه
والتجاريه على مستوى العالم على ان
السودان يتمتع بامتياز فريد حين يتعلق
الامر بالصمغ العربي اذ يستاثر هذا البلد
بما يزيد على ثلثي الكميه المنتجه على
مستوى العالم فضلا عن استئثاره باجود
اصناف اشجار انتاج الصمغ كشجر الهشاب
والطلح وغيره
هكذا هو الحال في قرى هذه الولايه الوادعه
يتنادى اهالي قريه بركات في محليه ام
روابه حاملين ادوات نضالهم المحببه الى
قلوبهم الفاس والمكمك والسونكي
يشحدونها بشغف وحماس واستعداد منقطع
النظير لانطلاق موسم الطق وهي عمليه شبيهه
بعمليه تلقيح اشجار النخيل
ان هذا هو دور اشجار العم حسين وهو احد
اعيان قريه بركات الذي تحدث لاهالي قريته
مرحبا بهم وشاكرا اياهم على وقوفهم الى
جانبه في هذا الموسم
موسم الحصاد السنوي الهشاب
هذه غابه قريه بركات وهي من الغابات
المنتجه للصمغ العربي
هناك اليه معينه لطج فروع هذه الاشجار فهي
لابد ان تكون في جهتين وليس في كل الجهات
والحكمه من ذلك ان يصل ضوء الشمس للفرع
الذي تعرض للتعريه من جهه الشرق والاتجاه
الذي يبقي ذلك الضوء حتى المغيب
المطر هو افضل غذاء لاشجار الهشاب المعطاء
وحراره الطقس سبب اخر لحماس هؤلاء
المنتجين المحليين اذ تعمل حراره الطقس
على استواء لحاء فروع الاشجار التي تتم
على مستواها عمليه الطج وهي عمليه نزع
اللحاء لافساح المجال للصمغ ليتدفق بعد ان
تكتمل عمليه التمثيل الضوئي
طقيتها من دون رياضه حبوب لكن لازم خلاها
تستوي سافانا دي تمام سافانا الغنيه دي
تستوي حته تنتج انتاج عالي لكن اذا طقيت
غيري
بعد ان عايشنا عن قرب انطلاق موسم طق في
احدى قرى ولايه شمال كردفان الغنيه
بالخيرات الوفيره كان لزاما ان نبحث بعمق
عن ماهيه هذه الماده التي تدر الملايين من
الدولارات سنويا وتعود بالنفع على ملايين
الاسر في هذه البلاد
تبعد المسافه بين الابيض وعاصمه البلاد
الخرطوم 500 كيلومتر وهذا الطريق هو نفسه
الذي يستخدم في عمليه التصدير عبر ميناء
بورتسودان على البحر الاحمر
هذه الولايه تقدم الكثير من الخدمات
والتسهيلات لكل المرتبطين والمهتمين بهذه
الصناعه بل ان المسؤولين يشجعون الجميع
للاستثمار في هذه الصناعه لما تتمتع به من
مميزات تفضيليه
لعل من ابرز نقاط القوه
للمستثمرين في هذه الولايه وجود المؤسسات
العلميه التي تعمل على
انتاج التقنات
التي تزيد من انتاج الصمغ العربي وتحسن من
نوعيه المنتج للسما العربي الولايه زاخره
بالمعاهد العلميه البحثيه والجامعات
وايضا الولايه ممكن يعني نحن برضه من
النقاط القوه عندنا اللي هي الهيئه
القوميه للغابه
توجهنا بعد ذلك الى احدى الغابات التي
تشرف عليها محطه ابحاث الابيض للبحث في
اسرار اشجار انتاج الصمغ لتبدا العمليات
الفلاحيه بجمع البذره من المواقع
اللي فيها الاشجار نحن بنسخ فيها كباحثين
عاليه الانتاج وبنجي نزرع هذه البذره دي
في المشاكل ثم بعد ذلك ننقل هذه البشره
البزره الى المواقع في الحق خصوصا انه في
محطه بحوث الابيض عندنا غابه
حوالي
7,500 فدان كلها مزروعه بالخشاب في بعض
المناطق صح الهجاب بقوم بصوره طبيعيه
لكن هنا عندنا في في البحوث او في محطه
بحوث الاوبيض في غابه معروفه ومعلومه
لكثير من الناس هي اصلا فيها اشجار بتاعت
هشام
لانتاج الصمغ العربي
[موسيقى]
نحن في الغابه ذي بنشتغل تجارب عشان كذا
بنكون محددين عدد اللقطات اللي احنا
عايزينها من كل يعني تجربه من التجارب او
من كل الاشجار
نحن الان مشاهدينا وصلنا الى غابه
الدموكيه وهي اكبر غابه بحثيه موجوده في
ولايه شمال كردفان هذه الغابه هي
اكبر غابه بحثيه انشات لاغراض البحث
العلمي لانتاج الصمغ العربي نحن الان في
موسم
الحصاد
وهذه اشجار الهشاب في هذه المنطقه التي
زرعت قبل سنوات لتنتج كميات من الصمغ
العربي
نحن الان امام شجره الهشاب واحده من
الاشجار المنتجه للصمغ العربي واللي هي
الاكيشياء سنغال
معروفه هنا في شمال كردفان والصمغ وطبعا
معروف في منطقه شمال كردفان او كردفان
بصوره عامه بانه الصمغه الكردفاني معروفه
عالميا لانه بيتميز بمناخ مختلف تماما من
حيث التربه ودرجه الحراره والرطوبه
فانتاجوا عالي فانتهت مرحله الطق ونحن
بدينا مرحله الله جيت او اللي هو حصاد
الصماء العربي فالان ما شاء الله ان احنا
شايفين الصمغ يعني موجود في الشجره بصوره
واضحه جدا وهو تحديد ال45 يوم من التاريخ
الطق اول لقطه عشان يكون حجم الكعكول
معقول ويسموه زي نضج يعني بالنسبه لي ده
بنسميه ونحن الكعقول يعني فبيكون نضج
وبيكون جاهز لانه للحصاد يعني
لزق جدا امر الحصاد بيتم طبعا بالسمك
والله
طبعا من الجلد الى البقر مثلا
في البتاع ده
[موسيقى]
طبعا الصمغ هو عباره عن كربوهيدرات اللي
هو مواد كربوهيدراتيه
وبالاضافه لبعض البروتينات السكريه وهو
غذاء الشجره نفسه اللي هو اللي بيتكون من
امتصاص الماء من التربه بواسطه الجزور
ويتم تصنيع الغذاء بتاع الشجره في الاوراق
وبالتالي بيتخزن في الخلايا المختلفه في
اجزاء الشجره وبيمر عبر اللحاء وطبعا
كمزارعين وقاعدين في المنطقه دي والمنطقه
فيها اعشاب وبعد ما ننتهي من حصائل الحصاد
بتاع الزراعه من
الهشام لانه اعتباره عايد لينا تاني عشان
نقدر نقدر شغل جديد من هو من طوقه وابعد
45 يوم بدينا الانتاج تاني بعض كل 15 بدك
انتاج يعني يعني كويس جدا يعني طوال بعض
الحصاد انتم بتكون
تعني لكن
لكن الرغم انه مخلينه لانه
عمال يعني طريقه نخليها شغالين فيها
للحاجه المفروض تحصل وما حاجه سهله يعني
اي حاجه في الادويه
لكن راى منه اهله
بعد ان تعرفنا على طبيعه تكاثر هذه الشجره
وطرق الزراعتها وانتاجها وحصادها وتحضيرها
لموسم الانتاج الصيفي نتجه الى حيث يتجه
المنتجون والتجار الى سوق المحصولات
الاكبر في الولايه وهو سوق محصولات الابيض
[موسيقى]
دي البدايه مع بتاعه المزاد في سوق محصول
على طلبيه عاده المزاد بيبدا بالصمغه
العربي
عندي باقي المحاصيل السمسم الفول الخام
عبر البطيخ السنه مكه
التجار بالنافسه في بعضهم بعدك مرتب السعر
المناسب في المسير
المتوسط الصمو الصحي حاليا الليله ب
38,000
بعد ذلك تبدا رحله الصمغ التجاريه بدءا
بشراء المحصول بكميات كبيره وهو في حاله
رطبه ثم تجفيفه قبل معالجته من الشوائب ثم
تعبئته لتصدير المباشر او التصنيع المصنف
[موسيقى]
الطلب بيختلف من زبون زبون في عندنا نحن
بنشتغل خمسه مختلفه يعني من القماطي
الواحده مثلا بيشتغل
ابوايم فايف
حسب حسب الحجم الطرف يعني
صناعه المياه الغازيه العصائر
الادويه مستحضرات التجميل
وربما لا يعرف كثيرون ان لحاء اشجار الطلح
المنتجه لاحد انواع الصمغ العربي تدخل في
صناعه منتجات ذات استخدامات يوميه كاعواد
الكبريت وبعض انواع البخور وكذلك الالعاب
الناريه
وعلى الرغم من ان رواد هذه الصناعه ماضون
في تذليل الصعاب والتغلب على كل المعيقات
والتحديات الا ان بعضها ما يزال ماثلا
كتهريب المنتج عبر الحدود الممتده الامر
الذي يدفع ثمنه من اختار الاستثمار بالطرق
المشروعه فضلا عن بعض التحديات اللوجستيه
التي تتسبب فيها عوامل مرتبطه بتطورات
الوضع الاقتصادي والسياسي العام في البلاد
اكبر المشاكل اللي بتلاقينا هي المشاكل
بتاعه
الديمومه والاستمراريه والاستدامه حقت
الانتاج
واسباب كثيره منها القطع الجائر للشجار او
القطعه المقصود على الاشجار
والهجره الحاصله في في مناطق الانتاج من
قبل
المزارعين السبب الاساسي في قطع الاشجار
هو يعني او السببين الاساسيات اللي بيعدوا
الى قطع الاشجار هم الاسعار المدنيه
عالميا في بعض المواسم بتضغط
التجاره والمصدرين ومن ثم
المنتجين في الازهار مما تجبرون لانه
يمشوا لبدائل اخرى يعني غير السماء العربي
يتم تهريبه بكميات كبيره جدا عليها 45 الف
طن سنويا ودي نسبه كبيره جدا يعني المزارع
ممكن يكون اكثر شخص بيتاثر في في الامر ده
لانه المزارع تعبان وبيزرع وفي النهايه
بيلقى انه القيمه بتاعه الصمغ قلت او نقصت
من القيمه الحقيقيه بسبب التهريب
هذه محطه ابحاث الابيض التابعه لهيئه
البحوث الزراعيه حيث يعكف نخبه من الخبراء
على تطوير ابحاث تتعلق بتطوير صناعه الصمغ
العربي وزياده انتاجيه اشجارها
ولم تعد ماده الصمغ العربي مجرد ماده
مسانده للصناعات المختلفه بل هي اليوم
بشهاده الخبراء غذاء ودواء لكثير من
الامراض المستعصيه
فعملنا بحث الحقيقه في الاول عملنا تجربه
سماه فايلة دراسه تمهيديه شن بعض الناس
عشان نعرف الصمغ ده مفيد ولا مفيد والجرعه
كما مفيده
ودراسه التمهيديه اخذت سنه كامله وعرفنا
بها الجرعه وهل في اعراض او ما في اعراض
في اضرار جانبيه او ما في
هل هو مفيد ام لا فعلا وجدناه مفيد ثم
بدانا البحث حقنا جبنا مجموعه من الناس
خليناهم سته اشهر بدون ما يحدث صمغ ما
ياخذ اي حاجه وتابعنا قراياتهم كلهم عندهم
فشل كلهم من الدرجه الثانيه الى الرابعه
وتابعناهم خلال سته اشهر وجدنا انه وظيفه
الكلى في تدهور مستمر
في الخط البياني حقهم
ثم اديناهم الصمغ العربي
وجلسنا الراغب كل شهر من عمل تحاليل
لوظائف الكلى ونكشف على المريض فوجدنا
الوظائف الكلى تحسنت تحسن ملحوظ
[موسيقى]
طعام ملائم من الدرجه الاولى بعد حليب
الام ما في غيره طبعا بيسموه حاجه اسمها
عاليه عشان كذا مشينا كل الامراض بتاعت
العصر مشينا على السكري مشينا على البدانه
الامساك القولون العصبي اسهل حاجه بالنسبه
للصمغ العربي
وهناك اتجاه حقيقي لنشر هذه الفوائد بصوره
عمليه وغير مسبوقه عبر تصنيع هذه الماده
في منتجات يسهل الوصول اليها وتناولها
والاستفاده من خصائصها الفعاله
هي اكبر مشكله كان بتواجهنا انه نحن
كسودانيين قيمه الصمعه العربيه سامعين به
كان هدفنا نحن الاول نوري الناس فائده
الصمغ العربي لو الريوني لين العالم كله
بيهتم بالصمغ الا نحن ما عارفين قيمته دي
كانت القضيه الاساسيه انها شغالين فيها
فنحن خلال الفتره اللي فاتت يمكن شهرين
شغالينوس في الحته دي انه بس هدفنا بس
نوري الناس انه يا اخواننا ده منتج سوداني
يعني الكوبايه دي هسه حاليا عباره عن عصير
او منتج شو فرصه خشب وفوته بلدي وفيه
حجاب وطلحه وتبلتي الثلاثه مع بعض والصمغ
فيه
مشاكل الجهاز الهضمي وبتساعد في حاجات
كثيره جدا جدا والقولون وحاسب دراسه الكلى
قيمه البريوتك اللي موجوده بس في 15 جرام
من الصمو حقنا للحشاء او الطلحه ما يعادل
تفاحه
هذه الصناعه الفريده تدفع السودانيين
للاعتزاز بانهم وصلوا الى مراحل متقدمه من
تطوير صناعه الصمغ العربي وان كانت ليست
في المستوى المطلوب بعد لكنها كفيله بان
تجعل العالم يتفاعل معها باعجاب شديد على
مستويات متعدده لدرجه استثناء هذه الماده
من قوائم العقوبات الاقتصاديه الدوليه
التي فرضت لعقود على السودان ابان حكم
البشير وكل ذلك التفاعل الايجابي يخرج من
مساحه صغيره من الاراضي التي تقع ضمن شريط
حزام الصمغ العربي داخل السودان الامر
الذي دفع بكثير من السودانيين للتفكير
الجاد في تمويل مشروع قومي يهدف لزياده
نسبه المساحات المنتجه لهذه الماده
الفريده
[موسيقى]